if you're angrier about my tweet
regarding yesterday's shooting in
Nashville Tennessee then you are about
the fact that six people including three
kids are now dead as a result of that
shooting then we have a real problem
here I support people who pray if they
want to pray praying if that's important
to them but it doesn't prevent shootings
and so when elected officials offer
nothing more than thoughts and prayers
and then we have another shooting and
another one and another one and they
continue to offer nothing more than
thoughts and prayers they were the
target of my ire not the victims of the
shooting and that I stand by 100 anyone
who knows me knows I would never blame
the victims of a mass shooting for that
mass shooting thoughts and prayers are
fine but we have to go beyond it I took
a shot at thoughts and prayers and every
parent I know is feeling the fury and
the anger and the frustration I've laid
out plans detailed to actually do
something about mass shootings 10
different points and policies none of
which by itself would solve the problem
of mass shootings but taken together in
conjunction with cultural and other
issues would dramatically reduce mass
shootings I get
not naive if you're a second amendment
fundamentalist it's convenient and easy
to go after someone like me who wants
gun safety regulations and we may not
make productive progress in figuring out
how to solve this problem maybe you're
part of the group that says there will
never be a solution mass shootings are
always going to happen they're here
forever and I was almost there for a
while and now I'm back to we have to
solve this we we have to do something
about this and as a parent myself and
speaking to other parents that Fury
makes a lot of sense so we should all be
mad I'm mad but we should be mad about
the fact that at this point as parents
and community members and teachers and
relatives seeing what's happening with
the deaths of children as a result of
guns taking NRA money is like taking
blood money we should be mad about the
fact that a huge number of our elected
officials openly say this has nothing to
do with guns nothing to do with guns
could it be mental health as a component
sure let's deal with it could it be the
culture surrounding firearms in the U.S
absolutely that's a particular problem
with the U.S but it has something to do
with guns as well and so when is the
right time to talk about that and the
fact that the thoughts and prayers don't
prevent shootings is it right after the
shooting well no you're politicizing it
it's too soon it's not okay they haven't
buried their dead well is it right after
the funerals is it in a month when
they've moved on from this shooting even
though we have one or two every day even
if they don't make the news when is it
is it right before the next shooting so
listen I tried something
to avoid falling into complacency not
everybody liked it I've been duly
chastised
but how and when do we take action I
leave it up to you so for everyone who's
been reaching out furious with me if
you're willing to actually talk
proactively about what to do and find
what can we agree on the lowest hanging
fruit that must be done to reduce
shootings I'm willing to talk to you if
you're on the side of making threats
sending me or my family threats
anti-semitic messages we probably don't
have a lot to talk about but anybody
reaching out in good faith who says hey
you know I get that you're angry I
didn't like what you said or at least
initially I misunderstooded
misinterpreted it maybe we can make some
progress I'm more than willing to hear
from you and talk I haven't given up I
almost did but especially as a parent
how can I say ah well we're never going
to solve this problem we have to solve
it or at least try the Tweet didn't work
okay from what I understand from what
people of faith and crude including
Christians realize that prayer alone
isn't working
we have free will
Free Will creates consequences in the
real world for our actions or our
inaction so what else can we do anything
we can do to prevent these shootings
must be done why aren't we trying lots
of the things that I've suggested that
we haven't yet tried if we do nothing
nothing will change that we can be sure
of and that simply cannot be